el escenario no dejaba de ser simbólico
voltao y avecino ucraniano y al este de
las fronteras de la Unión Europea
recibió a los líderes del viejo
continente entre ellos vlogylensky el
presidente ucraniano aseguró que recibió
apoyo en materia de seguridad de los
asistentes a la Cumbre pero pidió ir más
allá
estoy agradecido con todos nuestros
socios pero los Patriots son Patriots
con respecto a la coalición de aviones
para nosotros es importante que Estados
Unidos desempeña el papel principal ya
que los f-16 son sus aviones
la comunidad política europea fue una
iniciativa del presidente francés
Emanuel manco en su segunda reunión el
mandatario galo se mostró optimista con
el compromiso de los países europeos y
reiteró su apoyo a Ucrania
esta mañana me reuní con el presidente e
hicimos una declaración común afirmando
el apoyo en términos de preparar la
contraofensiva
la mirada se puso más al sur del
continente en los balcanes la atención
es palpable entre kosovo y Serbia y Mako
se ofreció como mediador junto con el
canciller olafones nos reunimos con el
presidente de kosovo Osmani y luego con
el presidente de Serbia bussius y
Acabamos de terminar una reunión con los
cuatro juntos reuniendo a ambos
presidentes alrededor de la mesa y
pedimos decisiones claras para la
próxima semana
sobre la mesa quedó la ampliación de la
Unión Europea muchos son los pedidos de
ingreso como el del anfitrión moldavia y
el de Ucrania unos nuevos integrantes
según las palabras de macoon requerirán
repensar la estructura del bloque de los